he certainly does he's got this team really
buttoned up they don't have the Taves they
don't have cane but they have a real good
mixture and they play the game the right
way they're coming off an OT win against the
Vegas golden knights kinsky for Chicago sent
it across and a goal and it's Conor Bard and
we're 28 seconds in oh what a shot it's one-
nothing Blackhawks has talked about it his shot
his ability to get open and find open ice and
look at how quick he gets rid of that puck it's
on and off the stick and look at the velocity
the stick B the snap and he puts a dart over
that glove of Ingram my goodness what a shot
all in one motion miss the game Friday against
the Kings melli with it and now melli holding on
to it back out High a shot towards the front
coyotes s it away and they can't put it past
R along and in over the line Carone shoots and
he ripped it high and [Applause] wide play out
of his Zone in ster paired tonight right or
paired right now as Shawn dery steter will go
to the bench has a chance in front Carone scores
Michael Carone and he gets it right back and it's
1-1
get the puck great play here drive to the net
goes for the shot B on it and Carone picks up
the Loose Change there's the fan right through
the middle carcone says thank you very much and
he buries it that is a big time goal real good
response by this coyotes team backto back shifts
out of his zone for kerfoot Jack McBain smartly
sends one deep cero is there so is Seth Jones
Liam O'Brien comes in coyote spr it shot on
rebound they score Josh Brun on the followup
2-1 [Music] [Applause] [Music] coyotes comes
right after him and then the next shift they
come right out and we've seen brown down in that
area before last year all he's sniffing around
and he's at it again big time goal juicy rebound
off the McBain opportunity and the big man brown
right to the line taken away coyot try to follow
up and they will as carcone sets it up now back
out high for yo Alami hug St and now kuss across
Carone and he scars second of the night second of
the period for carcone it's a power play [Music]
goal and how important they are look at the work
by Lawson kuss down low and look at that feed
Krauss right across the seam carcone right in
his wheelhouse too much real estate to cover he
actually puts it back against the grain five hole
got the hot stick tonight is second of the hockey
love the fact that they had a response did not hit
the panic button in his words but Tyson said they
still feel they're a little loose in the dzone and
with their execution feel like they can turn that
make the game fast and make it more difficult for
the Black Ops taken away Ingram will steer it
along Coy's look to get it out right back to
Center Ice Carone two on one carcone tries to
drop it [__] in front looking for a rebound
and it's underneath and carcone just missed it it
comes in and they score I think he got it there
though Tyson or is that Cool's goal it might be
[__] I don't know I think it's Carone and it's
his first hat earlier in this shift beautiful
Outlet pass carcone takes it drops it there's
the chance what a save up and over the net and
this Puck's going to come right back to him
Logan kie right there on the spot I still can't
tell who got this goal I I think it I think it
went off of Soder Bloom right there and in I I
don't oh here's maybe a better look oh bounces
off the top of the net off the right shoulder
and just an incredible stop this coyotes goodp
now you you got to push it along Donado trying
to drag it to the front 4-1 they've been in this
position before they were in this position
last game and now cero to McBain he scores
oh three goals and three games Jack McBain
it's 5-1 it's nasty oh my Kut what a play
little saucer pass look at the Snapper
by the big man McBain what a pass by K
foot and look at mcbain's step into that
one top shelf nobody's stopping this and
as you mentioned part now O'Brien is out
he'll go to the bench and the coyotes kill
it off Michael Carone after it Travis
Boyd has it back to the front Jersy
[Applause] scores pinpoint shot [Applause]
61 a ball absolute missile turnover by the
Hawks herone throws that out front and that
just finds dery somehow in the middle of the
ice turns and fires right-handed shot [Applause]
Mo Bren that time though taking a
run at w Kaiser you love the fact
that a guy like oen McBain Brown they
all continue the same play the same
way McBain with a shot rebound oh it's
put home no goal no they're saying no
goal we're going to take another look at
this Neil O'Brien certainly thought this
went in move and ability to create separ
ation by McBain and I'm not sure that was
kicked in I think they want to take a
peek at this one let's see you see a
kicking motion I looked like he directed it
but I didn't see that skate lead the ice and
kick pun review with the situation room we
have overturned the call in the ice there you
go Motion we have a good ball yeah baby out a boy
but um I just can't imagine this team without him
but he's off to uh other Ventures and we wish
him the best don't we yeah we certainly do and
I'll tell you what I can't thank him enough
for giving me this opportunity believing in
me and take it away Tyler Johnson's got
it sent it across but picked off by Alex
KERO MC B right down the middle tried to
drop it off and he scores oh what a feed
from ker unbelievable Jack mcpain
it's [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music] 81 what a play that strip
the pop back to come the other way McBain
dancing around gives it to curo side door and
Ming gets it right back look at the moves at
the bad case of dangas by McBain and what a
feed by kerfoot back door Beauty little tap
end there steter that's going to be cleared out
and the coyotes even their Mark tonight they're
four and four they'll head to Anaheim with all
sorts of momentum Tyson two words team effort